live at the senate floor right now the
second impeachment trial for now former
president trump
it's underway and a vote is expected
this hour on whether a trial is
constitutional
and if it will go forward we will bring
you that as soon as it happens
now earlier today house impeachment
managers arguing that former president
trump incited an insurrection
at the capitol on january 6th they want
to call the trial
over before any evidence is even
introduced and if we buy this radical
argument
that president trump's lawyers advance
we risk
allowing january 6th
to become our future presidents can't
inflame insurrection in their final
weeks
and then walk away like nothing happened
the president of the united states sided
with the insurrectionists
he celebrated their cause and trump's
lawyers responding saying the
impeachment trial is partisan
and will put the future of the
presidency at risk
we can't possibly be suggesting that
we punish people for political speech in
this country
with this trial you will open up new and
bigger wounds across the nation
for a great many americans see this
process for exactly what it is
a chance by a group of partisan
politicians
seeking to eliminate donald trump from
the american political scene
but at the end of the day this is not
just about donald trump
or any individual this is about our
constitution
and abusing the impeachment power for
political gain
jesse another year another impeachment
let's get your take on the
proceedings as it opened today
he's going to be found not guilty and
everybody knows what's going to happen
it's not even a real trial dana chief
justice roberts isn't even going to be
there under the constitution he doesn't
have to
and the jurors have already made up
their minds many prominent scholars
don't even believe this whole thing's
constitutional
and if you look at the precedent it's on
the president's side
throughout history congress has rejected
impeaching officeholders once they've
left office
and i don't know how you can say that
this was incitement because under the
criminal code
it doesn't fall under incitement it
falls under protected speech
it's not an insurrection either it was
an ugly scene but this wasn't fort
sumter
people didn't even fire a shot on the
mob side so let's not
act like this was more than it was as
distasteful as it was
right now democrats no credibility they
backed a mob
all summer which was deadlier and more
costly
they bailed out the mob and then when
the mob came to their house
they screamed law and order so i'm not
listening to what they have to say
i'm not listening to what joe biden has
to say either his credibility is shot he
ran
on tackling kovid and now he's wasting
time
he should be tackling kovid 60 000
people have died from covet
since he was inaugurated millions of
people are out of work
and he's playing games in the senate
right now
dana perrino this is about the democrats
midterm
strategy they're unified in their hatred
for donald trump
they're trying to use that unity to
divide republicans
and that's what all this is about and
maybe throw cnn a bone so they can juice
their ratings one last time
before those ratings fall off a cliff
for the next four years
and i'm told that the senate is now
currently voting um right now on this
question of is this constitutional will
it go forward
that is expected to pass the trial
expected to go forward
uh juan williams want to take a listen
to bruce castor who
is one of president trump's lawyers who
said that they had a
change of strategy after listening to
the house democrats he is
i'll be quite frank with you we changed
what we were going to do on account that
we thought that the house manager's
presentation
was well done and i wanted you to know
that we have responses to those things
and then they went through those
responses um not all of them today of
course this is on the constitutionality
question so one let's get your thoughts
on today i'm
sure they're not in line with jesse's i
could guess
no no unfortunately i mean i well i
watched i
i i was watching and i was amazed in it
because
to my mind if that's trump's best
defense
he's in big trouble and you know i think
jesse's right on one point
going into this i thought for sure
there's no way that you're going to get
enough republicans
to vote to convict donald trump but you
know i mean we're ready today we saw 11
republicans vote against what were
bipartisan rules just for the process
clearly signaling their distaste
for this impeachment proceeding but you
know senators do take an oath to be
impartial jurors here and it's always
been a fig leaf in my mind to say
oh this is uh you know th this is not
fair to donald trump uh they're only
impeaching him uh
because they don't like him or because
he's out of office but what we heard
from those two lawyers today was so
so off the cha i don't know where to
begin it's like oh
my senator why do we say my senator we
love senators or
this is partisan this is look they
didn't speak to
any of the real issues on the table that
was so
weak so i think the fig leaf is gone
and for if you're a republican senator
who took an oath to be an impartial
juror i think now you're going to have
to deal with a public
that saw that there was no defense at
all
either for the idea of having this
impeachment hearing or
for the seriousness of what we saw on
the videotape today
which was an attempt to stop an election
from being certified by the united
states congress which would be a
violation of the
constitution so to me the process
argument melted away today and it just
exposed the trump side i don't know what
they do going from here but boy that was
a bad showing they had today
that was uh professor alan dershowitz
katie he also was on twitter saying
not great but maybe they can bring it
home as i got through the end of
that and of course that just ended um
just right before we started the show
and they are voting right now we'll
bring that final vote to you as soon as
it
takes place okay to get your thoughts
now
well the first oath that u.s senators
take is to the constitution and
republican senators have already voted
prior to the
trial starting and they believe this is
an unconstitutional process
and for me it comes down to what is the
role of the senate and the role of the
senate and impeachment is to decide
on removal of a president now president
trump is no longer the president and
that is exactly the legal argument that
his team made today about the
constitutionality of this process so the
house again is in a position where they
rushed the impeachment through
didn't call any witnesses in in house
hearings or committees to ask
questions about this so they had a solid
case before they sent it over to the
senate
and here they are again wanting the
senate to do the job that they failed to
do
in the house with the president who was
no longer
working in the oval office or in the
white house and so
the point is moot for a lot of people uh
republicans have voted that's
unconstitutional upholding their oath
and that's where we are the process
actually really does matter when you're
talking about institutions
that need to be respected and far left
house democrats have proven over and
over again
they're willing to erase all of that for
political political expediency
and to go after president trump not
thinking about the long-term
consequences of
turning the senate into the house of
representatives uh which of course
and then there's lots of that attempts
right even on filibuster reform which
would do
the same thing greg a final thought from
you well i guess i mean that look
maybe uh i think the reason why the
trump's lawyers don't look that great is
they don't have to
there's nothing here if the dems had an
actual good case
why did they have to lie to america over
it why did their
video not include the part where trump
says
this is a patriotic and peaceful protest
why did they leave that part out if
you're so confident in your case
why deceive us the truth should be on
your side
we're not talking by the way about
impartial jurors in this case right
this is an impeachment over speech
and definition of words everything that
you hear in the accusation
is 100 percent subjective